&gt;&gt; Oh Matt, you brought Spud today. Can I hold him?
&gt;&gt; Of course.
&gt;&gt; Hi puppy, you're so cute. How old is he?
&gt;&gt; Well, my little canine friend here is about two years old, so that's about 14
in human years.
&gt;&gt; Oh, and how old are you my human friend?
&gt;&gt; well actually I just celebrated my 30th birthday.
&gt;&gt; Happy Birthday.
&gt;&gt; Thanks, but why do you ask? How old are you?
&gt;&gt; About 200,000 years old.
&gt;&gt; 200 what, you look good for your age.
&gt;&gt; Thank you. What could I say?
&gt;&gt; But that's not possible, you can't be that old.
&gt;&gt; Well, I know. I'm not 200,000 years old, but modern humans are. You should know
that, you're a genetics expert here at Udacity.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, yeah I knew that. Yeah, modern humans, homo sapiens have been around for
about 200,000 years, but we're not the only kind of humans that's existed on
our home planet.
&gt;&gt; That's true. Homo habilis was around for 2.5 million years.
&gt;&gt; That's right, homo habilis, one of the first primitive forms of human lived
almost 2.5 million years ago before going extinct after a million years. In
total, they lived almost five times as long as modern humans have been alive
today. Actually, let's go look at the timeline and learn a bit more about human
evolution.
&gt;&gt; I'll go with you, I'm just going to go put Spud down.
&gt;&gt; Okay.